we’ve all chased lightning bugs as kids,
but what’s going on behind those glowing
behinds?
Hey Everyone Julia here for DNews
I grew up in the midwest and spent my childhood
summers chasing around lightening bugs.
There’s something about them that just captures
the imagination.
But such powers of light don’t belong to
just those bugs.
Bioluminescence is found in a lot of different
animals! imagine waves of a bright lights
trailing behind your ships.
Such a phenomenon was part of sailors stories
for centuries.
It’s even described in Jules Verne “20,000
Leagues Under the Sea” as a “milky sea”.
But it’s not just a story or a mystery,
really it’s all just chemistry.
Most of the time it’s just two chemicals
in particular: luciferin and luciferase.
Luciferase, is an enzyme which binds oxygen
and luciferin together.
This reaction creates a lot of energy, and
rather than being released as heat, it gives
off light.
The color depends on the way the luciferin
molecules are arranged.
While some organisms produce luciferin, others
have to eat the things that produce the chemical.
Or in the case of the angler fish, they house
the bacteria that makes the chemical.
When you think of glowing creatures you might
think of only lightning bugs or deep sea creatures.
But bioluminescence is surprisingly common.
It happens anytime time of day or depth of
the ocean.
So why do they do it?
Well it’s not for generating heat.
Bioluminescence is a "cold light."
Cold light means less than 20% of the light
generates thermal radiation, or heat.
Some creatures like the anglerfish use this
trick as bait to lure in prey, other species
use it as a warning, the glow worm signals
“I’m poisonous!”, or some species of
fish release a flash of bioluminescent goo
to confuse their attackers.
The hatchet fish uses it for camouflage.
Their undersides are lined with photophores,
organs filled with those glowing chemicals.
This tricks any predators that might attack
from below.
Normally a fish's silhouette against the sky
gives it away, but these photophores make
the hatchet fish blend in.
Pretty cool right?
And a lot of other animals use bioluminescence
for communication, Some scientists even think
it could be the most common form of communication
on the planet!
You might be familiar with this kind of light
display from lightning bugs signaling to find
a mate.
Some organisms shine when startled or scared.
The Milky Seas in 20,000 leagues was really
a bloom of algae, like the dinoflagellate,
Noctiluca Scintillans.
When these tiny guys get disturbed by a boat
or cresting wave, it triggers the chemical
reaction.
And they light up the sea.
Such dinoflagellates are currently putting
on quite a show off the coast of Tasmania.
But this is different from fluorescence.
Fluorescence is when an animal has proteins
that reflect light.
Kind of like how certain things glow under
a blacklight, some animals only glow under
certain wavelengths.
Like the elegant jelly which reflects blue
light.
Scientists genetically modified some animals
like rabbits and cats with these fluorescent
proteins from jellyfish.
Yes glowing cats exist.
In fact the development of this technique
won a Nobel Prize in 2008.
By creating glowing cats or sheep, researchers
can track the formation of certain biological
processes like nerves growing or diseases
spreading.
Other researchers in San Francisco are creating
glowing plants and trees that could light
up the night without using power.
To find out how check out this video right
here!
What’s your favorite light up animal?
I’m kind of obsessed with hankler..
I mean angler fish.. let us know down the
comments below…